I have another one of these
fill-in-the-blank triangle
proof exercises.
But this time,
instead of doing it
on my own little
digital notebook,
I'm going to do it
right on the exercise
because there actually are
tools so you can mark up
the diagrams.
So first they tell us that
segment BC is parallel to DF,
figure not drawn to
scale, fair enough.
And it's always important,
if we're going to do a proof,
to know what we're
going to prove.
We're going to prove the
triangle EBD-- so that's
this triangle down here-- is
congruent to triangle EBC.
So this one right over
here, that this triangle
is congruent to that triangle.
That's what we're
going to try to prove.
So let's see what
givens they gave us.
They say that-- and you see
when you scroll over it,
they show you which
two angles they're
talking about-- that
angle EBD, or BDE,
is congruent to angle ACB.
So let me mark those.
So I just click once to show
that those two are congruent.
Then they say that these
two segments, DE and AC
are congruent.
So let me mark those.
You just click on them.
Click on them once it
does one slash mark.
If you click on
it more than once
it will do more
than one slash mark.
Then we also know that these
two are congruent, BED and BAC.
So I'm going to
put two arcs here
to show that they
are not necessarily
congruent to these other two.
So I did those.
Now we have this one, BED--
which we've already marked,
that's BED right over
there-- is congruent to CEF.
So that's just telling
us that CEF, this angle,
is the same as this one.
So I can put the double
hash marks there.
And then they tell us that
BE is congruent to EF.
And then finally, they
tell us that angle DBE
is congruent to CFE.
I'll put three.
DBE is congruent to CFE.
So now let's try
to do our proof.
And they've already kind of
done a scaffold of our proof.
And we need to essentially
fill in the blanks.
So this first thing, they're
comparing two triangles
and they say these
two triangles are
congruent because
of angle side angle.
So where can we even
make that statement?
Well we have this
triangle right over here.
We can say it's congruent
to this triangle
up here by angle side angle.
Or, we could say
that this triangle
is congruent to this triangle,
because you have this angle
side angle, this
angle side angle.
So it's not clear, based
on just this blank,
which one they want
us to describe.
Let's go further
down in the proof
and maybe it'll
become more obvious.
Well then they have this
blank, right over here.
Blank equals blank because
corresponding parts
of congruent triangles
are congruent.
Once again, it's probably
based on which two triangles
we picked to be congruent.
This is going to be one of them.
But we don't know
whether it's going
to be that one, or
that one, depending
on how this proof is going down.
Then they say that triangle
ABC is congruent to EBD.
So then they say
that this triangle
is congruent to this
triangle, right over here.
Well, if down here, they're
making that statement,
then up here they must want us
to say that this triangle is
congruent to this
triangle, right over here.
So we can say that EBD, the
double arc, double side,
triple side is going to be
congruent to double arc,
double slashes, triple side,
so EFC, because of ASA.
There you go.
And it filled it in which
is a good indication
that we did it right.
Let's see, what else can we say?
So now, remember, we're trying
to prove that this triangle
right over here is
congruent to this triangle.
So based on this, we just said
that this triangle on the left
is congruent to this
triangle on the right.
Given that they're congruent,
what is useful information so
that we can get information
about this middle triangle?
Well this middle triangle
shares a side-- shares side EC,
with this triangle over here.
So we should say that side
EC is congruent to something
over here, which
will help us set up
that this middle
triangle is congruent.
So based on the fact that
EBD and EFC are congruent,
EC's corresponding
side would be what?
Well, it's the side that's
opposite the triple angle.
So it's going to
correspond to side DE.
So we could say that
DE is congruent to EC
because they're
corresponding sides.
They're both the sides
opposite this triple angle.
Segment DE is congruent
to segment EC.
There you go, and
that worked out.
And then they say triangle ABC
and EBD-- so that's this one
and this one-- are
congruent because--
and we already went over this.
There's multiple
ways that you could
say that could-- well
actually, no, there's only one.
They have this angle side angle.
That's why they are congruent.
So we have angle side
angle congruence.
And then we can say that
BC is congruent to BD.
Well those are corresponding
sides of congruent triangles.
Those are both the sides
opposite the double arc.
Opposite the double
arc, and then up here,
opposite the double arc.
So that's because they
are corresponding parts
of congruent triangles.
And then finally, so
let me mark those off.
So that is congruent to
that, corresponding parts
of congruent triangles.
And then finally, we
can prove the statement.
And actually you could
have probably guessed
what this last one was because
this was the end of the proof,
that EBD is congruent to EBC.
And that's, once again, because
you have side side side.
We've shown that
these three sides
are congruent to
these three sides.
It's congruent to EBC.
And you want to make sure
you get the order right.
So E is the angle opposite the
three sides on this triangle.
And it's also the side opposite
the three sides on that one.
And then, corresponding to B,
B is opposite the single side.
And over here B is
opposite the single side.
So it's going to be EBC.
It's congruent to EBC
because of side side side.
And let's check our answer.
Drum roll, and it's right.
Very good.